[Music]
in factories and workplaces across the
country
something is stirring the rhythm of
britain's economy is picking up
experts now expect the strongest
economic growth in decades
and this machine is part of the
explanation not so much because of what
it's doing pressing and churning out
electrodes for the rear view mirror in
your car
but why it's here this company brandauer
is among the first to use a radical new
policy announced in the budget
the super deduction uh 30 tonne high
speed stamping press
roughly costs about 230 000 pounds
um just for the press itself
and the super deduction gives us
approximately 70 000 pounds extra
allowance absolutely it couldn't have
come at a better time to encourage
spending the idea is that businesses can
write off large chunks of their
corporation tax bill not just the cost
of machines like this but an
extra 30 on top that might be a very big
deal
now it's still too early to know for
sure just what the impact of this
machine and
thousands like it across the uk is going
to be for the economy but two economists
i've spoken to say that could be looking
at business investment growth of
maybe over 10 that's the strongest that
we've seen in a decade and a half
that's good news but it's worth just
bearing two things in mind first of all
we are still bouncing back from a very
deep recession
second there are some economists who
think that the super deduction
might not be that super after all that
mike jar given how the chancellor
described it back in march
bold unprecedented action but remember
he's also increasing corporation tax
from 19 to 25 percent in a couple of
years
and it turns out that might be what this
deduction is really all about
it looks like the size of the super
deduction has been chosen
precisely to offset that effect of the
corporation tax rate rise
the tax rate is going up by 30 percent
is going to be 130 of what it is now
and so by giving a super deduction of
130
of investment it turns out that those
two effects offset each other almost
exactly
in other words it's not so much a
stimulus as a damage limitation exercise
indeed for some companies the main
impact is just to bring forward
investments they were going to do
anyway like this pallet distributor in
scotland the business was there for us
anyway i mean
regardless of the the super tax we would
have done this anyway
but it's certainly being a big help to
us
either way this plus the easing of
restrictions and the return of a bit of
normalcy
is at the heart of the big economic
story of the moment the economy
is bouncing back faster than most people
expected
ed conway sky news